[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain the 2014 short comedy drama
film called leonard in slow motion
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the protagonist of the movie is a
middle-aged man named leonard who has a
unique quality
he exists in slow motion but lives in a
regular speed world everything leonard
does is at a slower speed in general not
because he is lazy but because it is
just how he was born his drowsiness also
applies to the things around him for
example the liquid he touches flows in
slow motion defying all laws of physics
at the beginning of the movie we see him
running to his workplace in slow motion
of course while the world around him
moves normally at work his colleagues
make fun of how he pours his coffee into
a cup they have worked with him for
quite a while but his unique quality
never fails to surprise them leonard has
a crush on his colleague cheryl but has
never had the guts to confess it to her
every time he tries to talk to her he
stutters because of that plus his
slowness leonard has never been able to
utter a word to her one day at work his
boss calls him aside and praises him for
coming to work early and leaving late
but complains that his productivity is
very low because of his quality to make
up for it he invites leonard to his
kid's birthday party as a performer
leonard reluctantly accepts the request
and performs tricks at his kid's
birthday he bursts a water balloon in
slow motion to entertain them it is
clear from the trick that leonard's
power bends the laws of physics
cheryl who is also at the party cheers
for him his boss knows that he likes her
and asks him to go start a conversation
with her leonard confidently approaches
cheryl but stops when another guy starts
talking to her first
this has been a usual thing for leonard
he is so slow that he is always preceded
by others in every aspect of his life
later that day he returns home in
disappointment his day gets even worse
when his boss calls to inform him that
cheryl is wanted at another one of their
offices so she is moving to florida
within a week
on the bright side his boss claims that
the kids were very happy at his arrival
handle loved his water balloon trick
leonard knows that his boss is taking
advantage of his uniqueness but he
cannot quit his job because he wouldn't
get one somewhere else
at night while watching the tv a news
report catches leonard's attention an
energy drink called the shocks beverage
is being sued for providing people with
too much energy so that they go into
cardiac arrest it turns out that a
malfunction caused a chinese herbal
stimulant called chilo to overflow
during the production till now a total
of nine people have been hospitalized
due to cardiac palpitations and
dangerously hyperactive heart rate the
advertisement of the drink says that one
shot of shocks will provide you with
eight consecutive hours of energy
although the news report asks the people
to not consume the beverage distributed
within the last week leonard gets a
brilliant idea
he wants to try the energy drink and see
if it will increase his speed and make
him like everyone else however he cannot
find the energy drink in stores as they
have all been told to throw them away
because of the health reasons so the
next morning leonard brings his friend
to every dumpster in the town looking
for a pack of shocks that the shops have
discarded after searching for hours he
finally finds a carton full of the drink
in a garbage bin behind a convenience
store in the following scene we see him
chug down several bottles of the energy
drink hoping it will make him normal
lo and behold the drink works and
leonard can perform activities at a
normal speed now he speaks for the first
time in the movie and says this is
amazing he then throws punches in the
air fascinated by his own speed tying
his shoelace is an enjoyable task for
him that morning even pouring himself a
cup of coffee which doesn't take forever
to fill the cup makes leonard's day
he puts more effort than usual to run to
work that day excited to do whatever he
couldn't when he was slow leonard first
tells his boss that he is quitting the
job he then runs to cheryl who is in a
meeting in the board room leonard
excitedly barges in disrupting the
meeting and says that he wants to ask
her a question
cheryl and the rest of the room
anticipate the question but it never
comes
as at that moment the effects of the
energy drink wear off
cheryl asks him if he is okay to which
he embarrassingly and slowly replies
that he is fine all of a sudden
leonard's stomach starts to grumble the
amount of energy drinks he had yesterday
is finally making him sick when no one
expects it he projectile vomits through
the room his co-workers including cheryl
watch in disgust as the vomit slowly
falls all over the desk even his vomit
doesn't follow the rules of gravity
everyone then gets out of the room
leaving an embarrassed leonard alone his
boss comes in after a while and asks him
to clean up the mess before leaving the
job forever
in the following scene leonard walks
into an old age home where he has gotten
a new job to take care of old people the
job is perfect for him as the people
there are as slow as him which makes him
feel included and normal he is way
happier there than he was at his
previous workplace leonard also writes a
letter to cheryl apologizing for ruining
her meeting and asking her to visit the
old age home as it is pretty close to
the florida office that she has
transferred to in the last scene leonard
is in a swimming pool where cheryl joins
him indicating that they have finally
started dating
the fans have called leonard in slow
motion a movie that is ahead of its time
because of its bizarre yet thoughtful
concept and excellent execution although
it is only seven minutes long it leaves
an impression on every viewer some fans
have speculated several theories on what
leonard's uniqueness denotes in real
life
they believe that it is meant to signify
how people especially youngsters feel
like their life is going slower than
their friends and family
they are always comparing their
achievements to others not realizing
that they all have their own uniqueness
just as leonard did all of them are
going at their own pace and will
eventually achieve the things they want
to
if they try taking shortcuts to life
they might also end up vomiting all over
their workplace
i have another theory
man is too nervous to ask girl out so
man drinks a lot and then throws up in
front of her this sounds just like high
school subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out
thank you for watching